[MUSIC PLAYING]
A.D. JAMESON: Thanks
for having me.
I'm thrilled to be here.
Thanks to everybody
for coming out.
JOSH PYLE: So, today we want
to learn a little bit more
about you and your
book and maybe a little
of your own background
in geek culture.
A.D. JAMESON: Well,
I've always been a geek.
I remember some of the earliest
movies I remember seeing
were things like the
"Muppet Movie" and "Return
of the Jedi," "ET," things
like that and grew up loving--
like a lot of people,
just watched "Star Wars"
all the time and stuff like
that, a lot of animation,
puppetry stuff.
And then I got really
into "Star Trek"
when I was in grade school,
high school, got really
into "Star Trek Next
Generation," "Deep Space Nine,"
"Voyager," things like that.
And I've always been
interested in geek culture.
But the funny thing
was growing up
with that stuff in
the 1980s and 1990s,
I got to be around
like 20-something,
and I thought, OK,
liked all that stuff.
It was fun.
It's kind of for kids.
That's what the culture
kept telling me growing up.
You like that stuff now.
Now it's time to be an adult,
move on, do something else.
Sell your magic cards,
stop doing this.
And then it exploded.
And if anything, it just
has become even bigger
in the past 20 years.
So instead of having to put
that stuff aside and move on,
do something else, instead it's
become everywhere to the point
where I could write a book
about it, a mainstream book.
So I never had to grow up
or put that stuff away.
JOSH PYLE: So it's just
been a constant evolution
the whole time.
A.D. JAMESON: Yeah.
It just keeps getting bigger
and bigger, the geek culture.
JOSH PYLE: So, geek
culture and writing--
so as a creative
writer, I'd love
to hear more about
your background
and how you got your
start as a writer.
A.D. JAMESON: Well, I became
interested in creative writing.
I've written short stories and
novels and things like that.
And I think I've always just
been interested in fantasy.
Growing up I liked those things.
A lot of the reason I wanted
to write in the first place
was I'd watch things like the
"Muppet Show" or "Star Wars"
or "Star Trek" and I'd
want to write something
like that, "Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles," whatever.
I mean, as I got older and I
started reading other things,
I started reading
non-geeky things.
But I grew up
reading like "X-Men"
comics and "Lord of the
Rings" and that kind of stuff
and fantasy novels.
I read Dragonlance novels.
Do people know
Dragonlance novels?
When I went to college--
and I went to college
originally for math and science.
And again, I was like
a stereotypical like--
I thought, I'm going
to be an engineer
because I love Geordi La Forge.
He's like my hero, and I
want to live on the Starship
Enterprise, so I'm
going to go to college,
get a science
degree, and I'm going
to work to try and bring about--
like help invent
transporters or something.
But in my case,
what happened was
I also really loved art
and the storytelling
and the movies and TV and
comics and all that stuff.
And I always drew and wrote.
And I got to college, and I just
find myself gravitating more
and more toward the art kids.
There's always a lot of
overlap between people in STEM
disciplines and the arts.
And I think actually
people forget
sometimes how much of an overlap
there is between the two.
And I'm an example
of that myself.
But in my case,
I think my love--
I realized what
I liked more were
like the TV shows and the
movies and the comics and stuff.
And I started finding
myself wanting
to take more creative writing
classes and less differential
calculus classes.
And so I just slowly
followed that passion.
I still like math and
science and all that.
I think that in
my case I realized
was more of a hobby
or something I liked
reading nonfiction books about.
And then I went more toward
story writing and fiction.
The weird thing,
though, is when I
went into a creative writing,
of course, the first they try
and do-- if anybody
here has ever
taken especially a college-level
creative writing class,
is they try to beat
out of you an interest
in fantasy and science fiction
and any of that kind of stuff.
They want you to write
literary fiction, which
would be like stuff that's more
like the kind of fiction novels
that don't really have aliens
or ghosts or things in them.
JOSH PYLE: You
wouldn't necessarily
see that in like Faulkner.
A.D. JAMESON: Exactly,
yeah, and they certainly
don't want you to
write genre fiction.
They don't want you to write
like Dragonlance novels or say,
I'm going to write the next
"Star Trek" novelization
or things like that.
So I went through a period
where my teachers really
did their best to kind of push.
And I was a writer--
it coincided right around
that time when I thought,
OK, I'm growing up.
I'm going to have to
leave this stuff aside.
So one of my
interests, then, ever
since then-- because
I just finished
my PhD in creative writing.
And so I do have more of
an academic career as well.
And I teach creative
writing at university.
And I know, I understand
where that literary fiction,
genre fiction divide has
come from commercially
and historically.
But I'm also interested
in bridging that gap
and kind of doing both.
So that's kind of the
challenge for me in my career.
And a book like this
is as an attempt
to try to show that a lot
of that genre stuff, a lot
of the geek culture stuff,
actually can have and often
does have a real literary
or artistic merit to it
that I think often
gets overlooked.
JOSH PYLE: And that's something
want to maybe focus in
on a little bit.
One of the authors you
referenced a lot of your book
is Biskind, who wrote the book
"Easy Riders, Raging Bulls."
Knowing "Star Wars" is the
focal point of this book,
that was one of things
that drew me and got
me pretty excited about it.
I saw "Star Wars" when
I was four years old.
I'm dating myself.
I saw it in the theaters.
A.D. JAMESON: Very lucky.
I did not.
JOSH PYLE: Yes, indeed.
True story, I
actually fell asleep
in the most climactic
scene of the film,
because I was four years old.
Since then, I watched it
a few hundred more times.
So, "Star Wars" in
1977 was very much
a product of its times
in a lot of ways.
So, Lucas was a contemporary
of people like Francis Ford
Coppola, Martin Scorsese.
Yet in some of the
criticism works by Biskind,
he seems to cut him
off from that group.
So I'd like to hear
more of your thoughts
around what I think you
refer to in the book
as "the new Hollywood."
A.D. JAMESON: Yeah, going
back to the last thing I said,
there's been a long tendency
to separate high art
and the literary--
like if you go over to the
Art Institute, for instance--
if you go over to
the Art Institute
and look at the paintings that
are on the wall at the Art
Institute and then you
buy a pack of Magic cards
or a pack of Pokemon
cards or something,
you can see that the Pokemon
cards and the Magic cards
are not hanging on the
wall at the Art Institute.
And if you talk to
people who are in--
especially film critics
or literary critics,
the kind of books they're
often talking about are not--
if anything, they often have
hostility toward pop culture
and especially things like
"Star Wars" movies and stuff.
So Biskind comes more
from that kind of--
he writes for "Vanity Fair."
He was from New York.
I think he thinks of himself
as being like a high culture
kind of guy.
And in a book he
wrote that came out
in the late '90s that's called
"Easy Riders, Raging Bulls,"
it's looking at '70s filmmaking.
And he tries to make an argument
that the last great decade
for American cinema
was the 1970s.
The last great films were
the films of that era.
And then ever since then,
"Star Wars" comes along.
"Star Wars" kind
of kills all that.
It betrays it.
And then ever since then, it's
just been pop culture junk
that you get, like '80s movies,
'90s movies, up until today.
Now it's just like the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and then
the "Star Wars" movies.
We've all heard variations
of that argument.
And I read his book
when I was in college.
And it was very popular I guess
a little bit after college.
And there's certain ways in
which I admire his argument.
But I didn't think he was
right, and I didn't really
agree with that argument
that "Star Wars" represented
the end of ambitious,
artistic US filmmaking.
If anything, I
thought "Star Wars"
was an example of
really ambitious,
artistic filmmaking and that
Lucas himself was very much
an example of 1970s culture,
that all the things that people
tend to praise about
'70s art cinema--
and when I say "art cinema,"
I just mean a lot of the stuff
was very mainstream at the
time in American cinema,
but like a strong
influence from European art
cinema, strong
influence from people
like Kurosawa, strong interest
in more experimental narrative
techniques.
Lucas was doing
all those things.
He was just as much into that.
And part of why "Star Wars"
was such a revolutionary film
was because of those things.
Those weren't things that people
were like, oh, gee whiz, I
like science fiction.
I'll just put up with
this other stuff.
It was, in fact, those
revolutionary techniques
in realism and
filmmaking that actually
made "Star Wars" the film
that people actually loved.
So I was like, "Star Wars"
wasn't a betrayal of it.
It was like the epitome of it.
And the things that people
love about "Star Wars"
are, in fact, those
particular things.
So just to give a quick
example, if you've ever
watched Hollywood
films from the 1960s,
a lot of films in
the 1960s Hollywood
are short on sound stages
and back lots in Hollywood.
One of the things they started
doing more of around '67 or so
and especially
into the '70s, they
started shooting
more on location.
So if you look at
a film like "Jaws,"
they originally wanted
Steven Spielberg
to shoot "Jaws" in a water tank
in the back lot at a Hollywood
studio.
And Spielberg said, no,
I'm not going to do that.
It's going to look corny.
It's going to look
like "The Creature
from the Black Lagoon,"
like a '50s film.
I want to go out onto the
open sea and shoot there.
And he had to fight for this.
And they actually fired
him off the picture.
He got fired because he was
going over time, over budget,
and it was very difficult.
And then they hired him
back on because they
were like, well,
he's the only guy who
can finish the picture.
But part of what we love about
"Jaws" now when you watch it,
like if you've seen "Jaws,"
is like they're really
out on the open sea.
And it's part of what makes
that film more powerful.
"Star Wars" was the same way.
There's a lot of science
fiction up until then,
where they're shooting
it-- if you've seen films
like "Forbidden Planet" or
like other science fiction
films of the period,
they're usually
shot in Hollywood
studios on sound stages.
And Lucas was like,
I'm going to go out
to like Tunisia and shoot there.
I'm going to go
out to Guatemala,
and I'm going to shoot there.
And that's a large part
of what makes Tatooine,
what makes [INAUDIBLE] look
like actual alien other planets.
I mean, they look
like actual locations.
And that's what's a lot of
people love about "Star Wars."
What people like is they like
the realism of the settings,
and they like those things.
And those were what we call
new Hollywood techniques.
And if anything,
I think fans tend
to complain about the opposite.
So when the prequels came
out, part of what people
didn't like about them,
a lot of Star Wars fans--
people do like the
prequels, of course,
but a lot of the
older, more traditional
"Star Wars" fans
said, I don't want
this to be shot on a
digital back lot in front
of green screens.
I want this to be short
on actual locations.
Why aren't they going out to--
I even think if you look
at "Return of the Jedi,"
one of the things
that always bothers me
when I watch "Return of the
Jedi," which is a film I love--
that was my first "Star
Wars" in the theater.
But when they go
back to Tatooine,
they're not going
out to Tunisia.
They go to Nevada.
They just shoot in
the desert there.
And it looks like a
totally different desert.
It just doesn't look the same.
And then the Ewok planet,
Endor, is the Redwood Forest.
I mean, it's lazy on some level.
I was like, by that
point Lucas didn't want
to travel anywhere anymore.
He's like, I made this money.
I'm not going out to-- he hated
traveling around the world
making these films.
He got sick.
His stomach bothers
him a lot and things.
So he was like, oh,
it would be easier
to go up to the Redwood
Forest and go over to Nevada.
And it's like that's what
he-- so it always bothered me
on some level.
It loses a little bit of that
far-flung kind of quality.
Not to say those things
are necessarily exotic,
but they're familiar from
other Hollywood films.
We've seen endless Hollywood
films set, like shot
in the regions that
are close to Hollywood,
because everybody goes
there to shoot them.
That's why-- because
they're right there.
They're just affordable,
and they're very available.
So making that extra effort is
like the realist new Hollywood
commitment.
JOSH PYLE: Gotcha.
Yeah, and as a personal
aside, just noticing
that-- when reading your book
I didn't actually realize that
until looking at the book about
some of those things and how
maybe there were some corners
cut in the making of "Return
of the Jedi."
Again, the realism
factor really stands out.
Like I think you
mentioned how when
Luke sees the droids
for the first time,
he's very dismissive because he
is used to that sort of thing,
the point being of this
world-making that's happening,
right?
And that's the world
that's lived in.
And I think you also talk
about that in the book around
Tolkien and how "Lord of
the Rings," for example,
how that was actually just
part of a larger mythology.
And it seems like
Hollywood in general
has been taking a while to
catch up to this, right?
You see that in "Star Wars."
You see that in
"Lord of the Rings,"
but that actually
goes further back.
And so you're beginning
to see more of that today.
So I'm curious about--
"Jedi" 1983 kind of dies off.
But then you have
this fan lore that
begins to grow around "Star
Wars," like role-playing games,
for example.
And they kind of pick up the
mantle for creating the world.
Maybe tell us a little
more about that.
A.D. JAMESON: Yeah, so the
book, there's a lot in there.
And kind of like the whole
book is like in those questions
in some ways.
[LAUGHS] I guess the easiest
way to explain it would be-- so,
when I sat down to write this
book-- and again, I told you
I grew up as a geek.
I also began to have
this experience where
I was dealing more with people
who taught literary fiction.
I had teachers in
my writing workshops
who said, you can't
write science fiction,
things like that.
I read this Biskind book.
I became interested in like,
why does that divide exist,
like why is there a
separation between high art
and genre often?
So that's one set
of questions I had
that I tried to answer when I
sat down and wrote the book.
And in some ways,
it's like a series
of prejudices I was trying to
overcome in writing the book.
But I also had a series
of questions about
like how did this aesthetic
of geek culture develop?
If you think of geek
culture as a community or as
a demographic, how did it
actually historically develop?
Why is there more of it?
Why is it more mainstream now?
Why is it more above
ground now than it was--
well, when did it start?
Like when did people
start cos playing?
Like when did it actually begin?
When did people begin making
up fictional languages
of elves or things like that?
Like there has to be a point
where that started, right?
When did people start
having conventions?
And then obviously when they
started doing those things,
it was clearly not as above
ground or as mainstream
as it is today.
So how did it develop?
And what are the forces,
the cultural forces,
that took it and made
it more mainstream?
So that was a real
question I had.
And one of the ways I got into
that was a question about--
I remembered from my youth
"Star Wars" disappearing.
And I'm sure you
remember this, too.
It's really funny,
especially if you're
a fan, it you're younger
than us or if you
know more "Star Wars" today.
There was a period between
1985, 1986 and 1991,
which again, that's
only like five years--
those five years were an
eternity when I was a kid--
where "Star Wars" completely
disappeared from the culture.
It just completely was
gone, which is shocking
because the movies were so big.
They come out in
'77, run through '83,
and by 1986, they
stopped making--
there were no more
"Star Wars" toys,
cartoons, no more TV shows,
no more comic books.
Marvel stopped
making the comics.
There were no more novels.
There was nothing.
They stopped making--
no more games.
It just went away.
And it's unimaginable to
think that would happen today.
So something clearly changed
between then and now.
And I was like,
well, what was that?
What happened?
The main thing was--
and this is what a lot of the
book ended up being about,
was even though geeks existed in
1986, even though they existed
in 1966, geeks
were very much more
of an underground subculture.
It was like a niche
culture that, growing up,
I didn't know many
people like me growing up
in Scranton, Pennsylvania.
There was like three of us who
were into this kind of stuff.
And the powers that be, a
lot of companies and stuff,
they didn't even realize
it was a demographic
they could actually market to.
And even if they wanted
to market to them,
they didn't know how to.
It was like, what
kind of products
would actually even buy?
What could we do?
What could we make?
So we begin to see--
the first people who kind
of really figure it out
is "Star Trek," because they
see-- when "Star Trek" was
off the air in '69, and
then all through the '70s,
they're watching "Star Trek"
fans have these conventions.
And they go, wow, these people
are really into "Star Trek."
They're really not
letting it go, right?
And they think, well, how can
we make some money off this,
right?
They're like, we
don't really know
how to make some money off it.
They don't want to
bring "Star Trek"
back onto TV, because that's not
going to be profitable enough.
They couldn't keep it on.
But they go, well,
what do they do?
And one of the
things they look at
is they go, well, they
write a lot of fan fiction.
They go to the conventions, they
see that all these people are
writing fan fiction stories.
And they go, well,
maybe we'll create
a line of "Star Trek" novels.
And we'll actually invite some
of those fan fiction writers
to come and do that.
So as it happened, in the very
late '70s when "Star Trek"
the motion picture comes out--
Paramount have their own--
part of the sprawling corporate
conglomeration they belong to,
they have their own publisher.
And they go, we'll just
hire some of these people.
They'll write
"Star Trek" novels.
And what you're seeing there
is the commercialization
of fan fiction.
It was one of the first
things they figured out
was, we could do this,
we could do that.
So Lucas hadn't
figured that out yet.
Paramount figures that out.
Lucas then doesn't
realize, even though he's
kind of a geek
himself, he doesn't
realize that geeks
exist as a demographic
and that they're
fans of "Star Wars."
As far as he's concerned,
it's a mass market phenomenon,
a mass culture phenomenon,
pop culture phenomenon,
and kids like it.
So he's trying to make all
the products for pop culture
and for kids.
But the problem is, pop
culture moves on very quickly.
It's super fast these days.
It moved fast even in the '80s.
There's a lot of stuff out
there vying for our attention,
and people are like,
yeah, I liked it.
I went and saw it.
And then I'm interested
in something else.
Some new movie comes
out or something.
You go see that.
Kids also age out of
products extremely quickly.
If you make toys
for kids, something
they like when
they're five, they
won't like by the
time they're seven
or by the time they're nine.
They age out of it very quickly.
So they just thought that
the market for "Star Wars"
was gone by 1986, 1987.
What they didn't realize
was that the geeks
were going to do the exact
same thing to "Star Wars"
that they had done
to "Star Trek."
They were going to keep
it alive themselves.
And if the culture,
if companies wouldn't
make those things for them,
they would make them themselves.
So they start writing
their own fan fiction.
They start making
their own costumes.
And they're like, we're
going to keep it alive.
We want to actually
keep experiencing
this world, this immersive
experience of "Star Wars."
One of things that
happens then is
a company called West
End Games in 1987,
they make role-playing games.
They go, let's get the
license to "Star Wars,"
and let's actually make a
"Star Wars" role-playing game.
People will play that.
So they get the license.
Nobody else wants "Star
Wars" at that time,
so they probably get
it for like a song.
And they start making the "Star
Wars"-- it comes out in 1987,
the "Star Wars"
role-playing game.
And the thing is,
if you're going
to do a Dungeons and
Dragons role-playing
experience with "Star
Wars," you actually
have to end up inventing
a lot of stuff.
So let's just picture
what it would be like.
You're playing the game.
You go to the Mos
Eisley Cantina.
There's all the aliens there.
Some of them are on screen for
like five seconds in the movie.
But you're in the cantina.
You can go there.
So you're going
to go over and sit
next to this guy
sitting over at the bar
and start talking to him.
What's his name?
Where is he from?
Now, none of this
is in the movie.
So you go over, and
there's a toy made
of the one, this hammerhead.
But you can't call
him Hammerhead, right?
Like that's just a
dumb name somebody
at Kenner put on the toy in 1978
because they had no idea what
else to put there, right?
The guy doesn't have a name.
I mean, the alien just
doesn't have a name.
So somebody at West End Games
had to come up with a name.
And they went, mm,
Momaw Nadan is his name.
And he is an authorian priest.
And the reason why he's
there in the cantina
is because he was a priest
on Ithor, his planet--
Ithor.
And it got attacked
by the empire,
and they wanted him to give
the sacred agricultural lore
of their planet, his
jungles, which are
like sentient, to the empire.
He refused, and then people
thought he was a traitor,
so they exiled him.
And now he's in
exile on Tattooine.
And he has a garden south
of Mos Eisley that he tends.
But he's also an ally
to the rebellion.
And he will
sometimes hide rebels
like in his garden and stuff.
OK, so now if you're
like the DM in this game,
you have a chance to
actually play this character
and actually
interact with stuff.
Maybe you could actually
go, we're on the run,
like when Momaw Nadan
is like, I'll help you,
and take her out to my garden.
You can actually play out
that adventure, right?
So they just have to
invent all this stuff.
And the people at
West End Games are
the ones who invented all this.
And so they put this book out.
It cost like $30 bucks.
And it sells out.
And it starts winning awards.
And by 1988, 1989, George
Lucas is sitting there,
and the receipts
start coming in.
He's like, hm, it's like money
from-- like "Howard the Duck"
just failed, right?
So he's thinking,
why is there money?
Nobody wanted to go see
"Howard the Duck," which
is playing tonight, by the
way, at the [? Music Box, ?]
7:00 PM.
[LAUGHTER]
I'll be there.
70 millimeter, too.
But he's like, what's
this "Star Wars" book?
And he looks at it, and he goes,
I didn't invent any of this.
Like what is this?
I didn't invent
any of this stuff.
But he realizes-- he's a shrewd
business person, Lucas is.
And he goes, there's
a market for this.
So he begins to think, how can
I sell this information back
to the geeks?
So 1991, Timothy Zahn,
the first thing they do
is they go, what
does "Star Trek" do?
They put out a series of novels.
They go, OK, we're going to
write a series of novels.
That's the beginning of
the expanded universe.
And look, these people
at West End Games
did us a lot of work here.
We're going to put
all this stuff in.
So they start actually
taking the RPG,
and they start making
stories out of them.
By 1996 you can read "Tales
from Mos Eisley Cantina," which
is a series of
short stories, which
is all the things that
were in that RPG book,
now told as short stories.
And one of them, of course,
is the "Sand Herder's Tale."
It's the story of Momaw Nadan.
It's just a written
version of it.
And then once they see
people will do that,
you can actually make
a toy now in 1996
that's a Momaw Nadan toy.
And it's a little more detailed,
and it has a backstory.
2006 you make an even
more detailed figure.
And gradually, they begin
to figure out, oh, there's
a demographic here that will
purchase specialized products.
Now, most people don't
want this kind of stuff.
My parents went to
see "Star Wars."
They have no interest in
buying a Momaw Nadan figure.
They don't know who he is.
They don't care.
But there's a niche
market for this.
And what they
figured out gradually
through the '80s and
'90s was they figured out
how to monetize it.
And then the other thing that
happens is the internet then.
You guys have heard of
the internet, right?
So in 1993 you have
the world wide web.
And suddenly people can start
putting all this information
online.
And suddenly you can
have the Wookieepedia.
You can look this stuff up.
Streaming-- you can go back
and watch all these things.
And suddenly, stuff that used
to be very hard to find--
and you say, well, "Star
Wars" wasn't hard to find.
But some of this stuff
was hard to find.
The "Star Wars Holiday
Special" was hard to find.
Issues of "X-Men"
were hard to find.
I remember trying
to buy them in 1987
and going into the comic book
store, which was like musty
and had water damage and smelled
like the owner's dog and stuff.
And went in, and there
was like cobwebs.
And I was like, how much for
that issue of "Uncanny X-Men
248?"
And he'd be like, $50.
It's like, well, I
can't afford that.
I want to read it, but
I can't afford that.
Now you can, whether
legally or illegally,
you can download these things.
You can read them online.
You can stream them.
If you want to watch the
"Star Trek" animated series,
you can watch on
your cell phone,
things that used to
be very hard to find.
So not only has
that demographic--
people have learned
how to monetize it,
that demographic has grown.
And now it's easier than
ever to get into it.
And guess what?
It tends to appeal
to people who tend
to work at companies like Google
or companies like Microsoft,
work at companies where
they have disposable income
and they want to actually
enjoy these kinds of things.
So increasingly, you see
that demographic growing.
JOSH PYLE: Yeah, even from
my own personal experience,
this past year was the first
time I'd ever gone to C2E2,
taking my daughter there and
realizing the crowd is growing.
Yeah, there's the cos
play and all that stuff,
but then you see
a lot of families
and you see a lot of
growth of just attendance.
And she's very excited that
the "Star Wars" celebration
is going to be in
Chicago next year.
I gotta give a plug for that.
But I guess seeing
that and seeing
that shift, what additional
opportunities are you seeing?
I think you spoke a little
bit about that from a business
and marketing side, like
from your perspective
as an observer.
A.D. JAMESON: Yeah, so
what you see over the past,
especially 25 years,
30 years, is you see--
so in some ways, I think of
geek culture and the growth
of geek culture as being
analogous to the invention
of teenagers that happened
in the United States
around World War II or so.
So, in the 1930s they
passed labor laws.
Suddenly kids and
teenagers aren't allowed
to work as much anymore.
They're a protected
class of citizens.
It wasn't like that before that.
After World War II,
the United States
becomes generally a
prosperous, peaceful country.
Of course, not everybody
got to participate in that,
but a lot of people did.
And you have this growth
of the middle class,
especially in certain areas.
And so you suddenly
had this youth culture
that has a disposable
income that
didn't exist before the 1930s.
And you have this
concept of a teenager.
And there's this
idea that if you're
a teenager, what are the
kind of things you should do?
You should consume pop
music, movies, go on dates,
go out for burgers,
things like that.
And you have a whole
culture form around this.
And once you have
that demographic,
they can begin making
products for that demographic.
So you can make things like the
"Beach Blanket Bingo" movies.
You can make drive-in movies.
You can make rock music.
You can have things like--
all those kinds of things.
Again, not everybody gets
to participate in this.
But a certain number
of people get to.
Geek culture is
something similar.
It's a demographic
that did not exist,
at least in the eyes of
Hollywood executives or people
like that.
I mean, geeks existed.
People with those
interests existed.
But they didn't actually
exist as a market,
as something that
could be marketed to
and specialized products
could be made for.
Part of what Hollywood
likes about geek culture
as a demographic is, one,
it's a growing demographic.
We have not hit the
limits of its size yet.
We're only like
20, 25 years into--
I would even say it's
only more like 15,
16 years of it being socially
acceptable on some level.
In my book I say 1999 is
the watershed year where
it breaks into the mainstream.
You can debate the
particular year,
but it's sometime around
the turn of the century.
And so it's still
a growth market.
More and more
businesses and companies
are getting into it, hoping
they can make money in it.
The other thing is, people
don't age out of geek culture
the same way they age
out of being a teenager.
If you're a teenager, how
long are you a teenager for?
Six years, seven years.
But if you're a geek,
you can be a geek
for the rest of your life.
I've been a geek for 40 years.
I'll probably be a geek
for another 40 years.
I'll be a geek my entire life.
I love this stuff.
I'm always going to watch--
I watched an episode of
"Star Trek Next Generation"
last night.
I'll watch them again.
So I'm never going to
stop loving these things.
So from a business
perspective, that's
a lifelong, heavily
enfranchised, branded consumer
who's always going to
be there and always
be looking to spend their
money and their leisure time
on those kind of
products that they like.
And the other thing they
like about geeks, too,
is that geeks, as
you can probably see,
geeks tend to be passionate
about the things they love.
They're heavily enfranchised.
They call us great
brand ambassadors,
because we will
go out, and we'll
talk other people's ears off.
We'll write blog posts,
make videos, all for free.
We'll make podcasts.
We'll write books
about the topic.
On some level, this
is a book I wrote
because I was trying to
answer certain questions
about the history of geek
culture and how it evolved
and how the aesthetics of
it have evolved over time,
but on some level, this is free
advertising for "Star Wars,"
right?
I mean it's right there
on the cover of the book.
Lucas didn't give me
anything for that.
I'm doing that for him.
So as long as people
are talking about it.
So that's a large part
of why-- it's still
a growth demographic.
And it's also one that
if you could actually
get those people,
get geeks, they're
a very highly valued type of
consumer from the viewpoint--
so two things I
can see are, one,
as much as geek culture has
saturated US culture and also
world culture, we're
nowhere near, I don't think,
the limit yet.
It's a growth
market, and I think
it's still a growth market.
And then it's going to become
an increasingly mainstream
culture.
And then on top of that,
the politics of it--
the really exciting
story in a lot of ways
is how the politics
of it are changing.
And I think you wanted to ask
a question or two on that.
JOSH PYLE: Yeah, for sure.
A.D. JAMESON: Because
that's what we're really
in the midst of now.
JOSH PYLE: Yeah, I think
that it's really important
to talk about that
because of how broad
the fan base has become and
how geek culture is very much
ingrained.
It is pop culture
in a lot of ways,
like "Star Wars" is
very much mainstream.
And I think it's
really important
to talk about that, talk
about diversity and inclusion
in the world of geek culture.
So it's exciting to see.
We've seen more of them
in the past couple years.
But then thinking about
that broader representation
in the culture, "Star
Trek," shout-out,
they that day one
with characters
like Uhura, Mr.
Sulu, and so forth.
"Star Wars" began to pick this
up, maybe a little slowly.
But then more recently, a
lot more noticeable strides.
And then Joss Whedon
has LGBTQ characters.
And then, of course, the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
with Black Panther
and Luke Cage.
A.D. JAMESON:
Slowly coming along.
JOSH PYLE: Yeah,
slowly coming along.
It's taken a few years.
And part of that adds more
complexity to storytelling,
too.
Because just acknowledging that,
thinking about Black Panther,
for example, the complexity of
a character like Killmonger,
very complex, a lot
of different things
you're processing when you're
seeing that battle that's
happening and some of
things he talked about.
But it seems that there's some
backlash also that's happening.
And especially I think it's
very noticeable with "Star
Wars," like "The Last Jedi"
being an example of that.
Tell us a little
more about your take
on that and why it is that a
certain semblance of geeks,
predominantly white
males, let's face it,
are having a struggle
a bit with this change.
A.D. JAMESON: Yeah,
so I mean, there's
a couple of things
going on here.
The first, of course,
is in pop culture,
just the politics of our
moment are obviously greatly--
we're living through
a period where--
you can think that there's
always different politics
in the culture.
But there's times
in our culture where
maybe politics are a little
more monolithic and top-down.
And at least people
publicly pretend
to agree on the same things.
And there's other parts
and other periods where
there are just conflicting
views that are both mainstream
and people are battling on.
We're clearly in one of those
latter moments right now.
So everything is
politicized these days,
and so we would
expect pop culture
and geek culture to be
politicized as well.
But I think another
thing that's happening
is-- so this growth in geek
culture and its mainstreaming
is really being driven
more than anything
else I think by fans themselves
and by geeks themselves.
Corporations are
coming in and trying
to actually monetize it and
figure out how to make money
off the demographic.
But remember, there were "Star
Trek" fans making their own fan
fiction before they figured
out how to make those novels.
And the geeks were making "Star
Wars" products before Lucas--
the corporations are kind
of falling behind and coming
in and trying to figure out
how to actually corporatize it.
And of course, as more
and more money flows in,
it becomes more and more
mainstream, more visible,
more public.
But if you think about the kind
of people geeks tend to be,
the way I describe geeks in the
book-- and anybody can be geek.
If anybody wants to say, I'm a
geek, you're a geek, whatever.
It's not like there's a--
you don't need a membership
card or something, right?
But traditionally
what geeks are are
people who tend to be interested
in two things at the same time.
They tend to like
fantasy of any kind.
It could be
animation or puppets,
or it could be science fiction.
It could be horror.
It could be any of these things.
But then they also tend to
be more technically minded.
And they tend to be interested
in the STEM disciplines.
They like the
sciences, whether it's
the hard sciences or the
more social sciences, math,
engineering,
computers, whatever.
And what they
particularly like is
to see the intersection
of those two things.
So there are people who
are interested in fantasy
but aren't interested in
seeing a scientific version
of fantasy.
They want to see a
crazy, irrational.
So like someone like
David Lynch would
be a good example of that.
He likes fantasy.
He likes the supernatural.
But he likes it to be
mysterious and weird and more
like a nightmare or something.
What geeks tend to do
is they kind of come in.
They're interested in fantasy,
but what they want to do
is they want to treat
the supernatural
as an extension of the natural.
They want to actually figure
out what the scientific laws are
or the biological, like
what's the history of elves
or what's their culture like,
what's their language like.
And so they begin
to kind of take
the supernatural
and the fantastical
and bring it in under rational,
empirical methodologies
and tools and frameworks and
try to actually understand it
that way.
So it's this intersection of
the STEM disciplines and fantasy
I think that traditionally
is what defines a geek.
So if you think
about it that way,
you've always had people of
all different walks of life
being interested in fantasy.
But the STEM disciplines in
particular, traditionally were,
if you go back historically,
if we go back and think
to the 1960s, 1970s,
1980s, it tended
to be a whiter male discipline
for various reasons.
My mom in high school was
really interested in science.
She wanted to be a
marine biologist,
and she was told when
she was in high school,
you can't be that,
you can't do that.
You should be an
English major instead
or you should become
a nurse or something.
So she didn't become
a marine biologist.
Hopefully that attitude
has changed today.
And as the STEM disciplines
and tech job and things
like that are themselves
diversifying, which
is long overdue,
of course, you're
seeing geek culture
also diversify and grow.
And again, that's
something I think
that's being driven by
the fans themselves.
And so the companies
are a little slower
to pick up on this.
But again, they're cautious.
They're trying to figure out
how to safely monetize this.
In terms of a backlash, I think
part of what you're seeing,
of course, is that for a long
time a certain group of people
perceived geek culture as
being their underground niche.
And I think it's two things.
I think, one, is
a lot of geeks are
kind of resentful to
see it go mainstream.
The same way if you're a
fan of an underground band
and then you see them go
mainstream, on some level
you feel like maybe
you've lost something.
You haven't.
Pop culture belongs
to everybody,
and you can still go back and
listen to the earlier albums.
But look, when I was growing
up, I loved "X-Men" comics.
And I suffered from this myself.
When I saw them making the
"X-Men" movies in 1999, 2000,
on some level, I felt
resentful about it.
Because it wasn't
the "X-Men" I knew.
I was like, look, it
looks at the "Matrix."
They're wearing black
leather jumpsuits.
They're using Wire Fu.
That's not the "X-Men."
When I was reading
it in 1986 and they
were in the Australian
Outback and the team
was Longshaw, Rogue,
Dazzler, Wolverine, Colossus,
it's like Havoc, Storm,
that's the X-Men.
I don't want to see--
they're changing things.
So I get it.
I felt like it wasn't
exactly what I wanted.
But here's the thing.
I was reading "X-Men" in 1986.
There were "X-Men" fans in 1976.
I was the new kid on the block
who looked obnoxious to them.
Like what are you talking
about 1986 "X-Men?"
It's not the 1976 "X-Men."
Then you have the 1966 "X-Men"
fans, who are like, wait, wait,
wait a minute.
Hold on.
We were here first.
The thing about pop culture is
that it belongs to everybody.
And it keeps evolving.
And it has to keep evolving.
And it keeps going in the
direction of our own interests.
I write in the book that pop
culture characters don't die.
They don't live.
They don't die.
The thing that happens to them
is that we might lose interest
in them.
So if you look at a franchise,
like a character like Dick
Tracy right now, Dick
Tracy seems to me--
if people even
remember Dick Tracy.
There's not much action
happening on the Dick Tracy
front, right?
There was the
movie back in 1990.
I guess the cartoon, the
comic is still being made.
Does he still talk into
the wrist radio thing?
There's probably some
Dick Tracy fans out there.
They're probably mostly
over the age of 40,
maybe over the age of 60.
And if you're going
to make something
that appeals to
people today, you
have to update it
to the present day.
So I think the smarter--
so some of what the "Star
Wars" franchise has done
is like, yeah, like
the time it was made,
there were way too
many guys in it.
It's overwhelmingly white.
If you want to update it today
and you want to actually make
it appeal to the people who
are the geeks today, absolutely
it should be much more diverse.
And I think it's a
confluence of these things.
As the geek
industries themselves
diversify as it becomes
more mainstream, as our pop
culture fights out
these political battles,
you're going to see
those trends continue.
So the two things I think we can
say about geek culture is, one,
I don't think we're
anywhere near--
as big as it is now, it's
going to keep getting bigger.
And then, two, I
think also the side
is totally on the side of
greater diversity and all
those things in geek culture.
That part seems to be
taking a bit of-- that
seems to be lagging
behind a bit more.
I think 2014, 2016
have kind of been
inflection points with Gamergate
and then the election of Trump.
I think a lot of these things
have bubbled to the surface
and really broke
through in a way
and created
visibility for forces
that people weren't paying
attention to before that.
JOSH PYLE: So we have just
a couple of minutes left.
In just a minute, we're
going to open up for Q&A. So
be thinking of your questions.
And the microphone is
just right over there.
So be thinking about that.
We only have time probably
for one question from me.
So I'm thinking
from the list here.
So let's talk about diverse
experiences a little bit.
So in the book, you
talk a little bit
of how you'd love to experience
the "Star Trek" holodeck.
And I think you also mentioned
in the book about holodeck
addiction, right?
But the point I'm
really getting to
is around new technologies and
the use of new technologies.
We could go on a
lot of territory
here, but the use of
technology for storytelling--
I think that's
where I would like
to get your opinions for
emerging storytellers,
people who are thinking
about world-building,
who know that they
have to create rich,
dense stories if they're
going to be the Harry
Potter of 10 years from now.
A.D. JAMESON: Yeah, so I
mentioned that the way I define
a geek in the book are people--
it's again this intersection
between people who like fantasy
and the supernatural, whatever
that entails, and then try
to bring a more
technical or scientific
or engineering based
mindset to bear upon it.
And they want to see the
intersection of those two
things.
That's a large part of why
geeks like realism, is because
in a lot of ways,
what they want to do
is they want to produce this
sense that the other world
actually exists as much
as possible, like we
saw with the role-playing game.
So any kind of technology
that allows them to do that,
if you think about it--
a movie is a technology
for having a fantasy.
A book is a technology
A comic book is that.
And I think a lot of geeks,
what they're driven then to do
is to try to create
immersive experiences that
allow them to actually
feel like they're
living in that other world
and having that experience.
They want it to be as complete--
you want to actually
be in there,
and you want to
be able to believe
you're actually in that world
and forgot that you were--
I mean, I know I do.
I would like more
than anything else
to go live on the
Starship Enterprise.
It seems like a much
better place than--
and particularly the Next
Generation Enterprise.
It just seems like
a better place
than a lot of where
we currently live.
I'd love to live in that world.
So if somebody actually could
build a replica of the Starship
Enterprise, and I could actually
just go walk around in it,
that would be my
life's dream come true.
It's like the best I'm going
to get if I can't actually
go live in that world.
If somebody creates
a virtual reality
headset, where I could actually
experience that, I'd love that.
And I think one of the
things you're seeing,
people are trying to do
that with VR and stuff.
But one of the more
recent evolutions,
and I'm not surprised by this,
is the creation of theme parks
that are modeled around
particular brands,
so like the Wizarding
World of Harry Potter,
where you go in,
you got the wand,
you can actually
interact with things.
Again, it's like you're
going to Hogwarts.
It's like this
amazing experience.
They're doing it with "Avatar."
They're doing it
with "Star Wars."
So I think, again, they're
trying to figure out,
because they have this
demographic, how they can
create that
experience for people
who will go and
will spend-- like I
want this particular wand.
I will spend $80 on it
and have that experience.
So yeah, from any tech--
it could be VR, it
could be 3D movies,
it could be video games.
It could be just
building the things.
People like to build
replicas of things and stuff.
But to have that
immersive experience.
JOSH PYLE: Yeah,
immersive, real, lived in.
A.D. JAMESON: Yeah,
a realist-- yeah, it
should look like an actual
other world you've gone to.
JOSH PYLE: Yeah.
A.D. JAMESON: Yeah.
It's like my cell phone
screen is cracked,
so why shouldn't the droids
have some scuffs on them.
That's what the real
world looks like.
We get hurt, so our
characters should get hurt.
JOSH PYLE: Yeah.
It's true.
All right, so we have
time for a few questions.
The microphone is over there.
So feel free to
step up to the mic.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for coming
to talk to us.
I actually was an English
major and a fantasy nerd.
But I was a Victorianist,
so I definitely
identify with your high and low
concept in literary criticism
idea.
And so my undergraduate
dissertation
was on Jacques Derrida's concept
of the archive, fan fiction,
copyright, and Tolkien.
A.D. JAMESON: Wow, good.
AUDIENCE: And the Tolkien
estate was very, very anti
the fandom participating
in and extending the--
basically he went after a
lot of copyright issues.
And I've watched
that kind of evolve,
and I'm very curious
what you think
about how fandoms are kind
of appropriating things,
continuing to expand
universes, and then
that fight between
what's canon, what's not,
where they step on copyright
issues, these sorts of issues
that you're getting
to talk about now.
A.D. JAMESON: Yeah, I have a
background in Victorian studies
myself, too.
And actually, it's related,
because the Victorians had--
you see an explosion
of literacy and reading
in Victorian culture.
And to this day, one of the
conflicts in Victorian studies
is like, what are the
actual works of literature?
What are the more
genre [INAUDIBLE]..
So that's part of the
relationship, my interest
in those two things.
Yeah, the Tolkien estate is
a funny one, because they--
when they first
approached Tolkien
like in the '60s about
making a movie out
of "The Lord of the
Rings," they could
see it was growing in
popularity, among especially
young people, hippies.
And his agent said to him, well,
do you want them to do this?
And Tolkien said
one of two things.
If they won't give
me any money for it,
then we should
insist on high art,
like it should be a great film.
But if they'll give
me a lot of money,
then I don't care
what they make.
[LAUGHS] It was like
one or the other.
And they actually ended
up selling the rights,
and then the rights-- there's
a really interesting book
on this called "The Frodo
Franchise" by Kristin Thompson,
where she went through the whole
history of how the rights were
caught up in legal battles
and why really the movie is
in some ways, besides
the animated versions,
didn't really end
up getting made
until the late 90s, early 2000s.
But yeah, the Tolkien
estate, though,
has tried to control
in a lot of ways.
And they don't like the
Peter Jackson movies.
And they're like, you're never
making "The Silmarillion," et
cetera, et cetera.
And they also claim they
never got any of the money
from it and stuff.
But the thing about
it is I understand
that if you're talking
about officially
licensed Tolkien
stuff, but at point,
the copyright will run out.
But I'm a real firm
believer that pop culture
belongs to everybody.
Anyone who's interested
in it, anybody
who reads it and has a--
when I was a kid, I loved
Lloyd Alexander novels,
the Prydain Chronicles.
They were some of the first
books I fell in love with.
They made a Disney film, "The
Black Caldron," out of them.
They're supposedly
trying to make a TV show.
And I sat there, and I wrote--
like those books end if
you get to the fifth one.
They end.
But I wrote Prydain Chronicles,
Lloyd Alexander fan fiction.
And I imagined myself into
the stories and meeting
Taran and Eilonwy and Hen Wen,
all those characters and stuff.
And you can't stop
people from doing that.
I don't see why
anybody would want to.
Now, I think the question then
becomes, anybody can do that,
but then if other
people like it,
it will go on and have
a life outside that.
If you want to write your
own "Star Wars" fan fiction,
you can do that, or your
own "Lord of the Rings" fan
fiction.
But it doesn't mean anybody else
is going to want to read it.
But the things that people
like will go on and become
fan favorites and maybe will
eventually get picked up
by these companies, I think.
I think they're actually
foolish if they ignore
those segments of the fan base.
Like with "Star Wars," it's
like Mara Jade is clearly
a beloved character in
the Star Wars universe.
Why they have not introduced
her into the [INAUDIBLE],,
I just think that's
foolish of them.
They should, that kind of thing.
And similarly, if
there's somebody--
I'm not quite as up on
Tolkien fan fiction,
but if there's
somebody out there
who's writing really good
Tolkien fan fiction and people
like it, I think they
should look to that
and maybe try to
adopt it or something.
AUDIENCE: I always
thought it was
really interesting
because Tolkien
himself was such a scholar
of Norwegian mythology,
Greek mythology.
He was basically
ripping off a lot
of archival, universal
stuff anyway.
So I thought it was
a bit hypocritical.
A.D. JAMESON: Oh, yeah, like
the stuff comes from "Beowulf."
It comes from the
"Nibelungen," it's
like he took stuff
left and right.
I mean, culture
belongs to everybody.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Thanks for coming.
I'm just wondering in
your definition of geek
and focusing on people who
are interested in STEM,
it seems to exclude a large
portion of the mainstream
people who might
identify as geek
and are starting to--
like the kind of people
who are really excited
about "Big Bang Theory"
or you mentioned "Harry Potter."
How do you see those
two worlds intersecting?
Where's the middle there?
There's certainly people who
travel in between those worlds.
What's in the middle?
A.D. JAMESON: Yeah,
I do define "geek"
a particular way in the book.
And in a lot of ways,
what the book is about
is the past 40 years
of geek culture.
It's kind of how we've had
40 years of "Star Wars" now.
How did the "Star
Wars" franchise
grow up and change
in those 40 years?
And how did geek culture change
during that time period, too?
And it's changed a lot.
And it's going to keep changing.
One of the things that
is happening, of course,
is that as it becomes
more mainstream,
the definition of it is
becoming a lot more diffuse.
And that's just an
inevitable-- again,
it's not that different
from something
like punk going mainstream.
Punk music is something
I'm really interested in.
And if you go back
in time to 1976, who
would identify as a punk or
being interested in punk music?
It's a very specialized thing.
Because it is a subculture.
It's a small culture.
Even by the time you
get to 1978, 1979,
what counts as punk music
was already really diffuse.
And nowadays, what counts as
that is all over the place.
So there's nothing to stop that.
And I don't even think it's a
thing that should be stopped.
As geek culture goes
mainstream, you're
going to see something that
maybe was more of a highly
specialized term or it was
more specific in a couple
of different identities
it referred to.
But it's going to expand.
And so, yeah, I think
you have very casual geek
fans these days.
That's how it is.
I mean, in a lot of ways, people
who are like hardcore geeks
and stuff should be
really grateful for that.
Because if it were
just the geeks,
like if you go back in
time, how many people
would have shown up to watch an
"Avengers" movie in like 1975?
It probably wouldn't
have made any money.
So they wouldn't have
been able to make it.
If you liked "Infinity War," if
you like the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, if you
liked the fact--
the fact that "Infinity
War" just crossed $2 billion
globally, the only way it can
do that is if a lot of people
beyond--
there's a lot more geeks
now than there used to be.
But even if all the
geeks in the world
showed up and saw
it like 10 times,
it still wouldn't make
$2 billion globally.
It wouldn't even come close.
So there's a lot of people
who are more casual fans who
are showing up as well.
And look, if they want to say
they're geeks, like whatever.
They're geeks.
I mean, I think of it
more as a spectrum.
On one level, it's
like people who
are just kind of like the most
casual fans you can imagine.
And then at the other end, you
have the most die-hard fans
who know every single thing
and are completely obsessed.
And I'm not even
at that end myself.
I don't know where I am.
I'm someone on the spectrum.
I'm probably closer to
the more enfranchised end.
But maybe it's only like 75%.
Trust me, in writing
this book, I've
met people who are
far more into it
than I am and are
far more into it.
I know people who all they wear
at home is a Starfleet uniform.
So it's like, that's great.
And then on the other
hand, you have some people
who just want to go to
Target and buy a T-shirt,
and they're a geek.
And that's-- you know.
But that's the sign
that it's going
mainstream, the fact that--
I think it's in many
ways a lovely thing
that it's something that's
more accessible to people
and they can choose their
level of engagement with it.
Its doesn't have to be--
because it used to be like
if you wanted to read--
again, I go back to "X-Men"
comics in the '80s, but if you
wanted to read these things,
it was hard to find them.
And I'm happier now that they're
accessible to more people.
So does that answer
the question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thanks.
I also selfishly
appreciate that it's
going more mainstream, because I
think it encourages more gender
diversity.
A.D. JAMESON: Yeah, totally.
AUDIENCE: Howdy.
I have not read your book yet.
And at the risk of--
A.D. JAMESON: I forgive you.
[LAUGHS] We have copies.
AUDIENCE: At the
risk of giving away
in the nucleus of
your argument, I
want to know what
interpretation I can expect
to take away from the title.
"I find your lack of
faith disturbing."
How do you tie that in?
A.D. JAMESON: Yeah, so
when I wrote the book,
I was just calling it "Star
Wars and the Triumph of Geek
Culture."
And my publisher
said to me, we have
to have a thing to
put in front of that.
And I said--
[LAUGHTER]
I said, well, why?
And they said,
because we have to.
And I said, OK.
So I mean, that
was their decision.
So then they said to me, they
said, we want to call it--
what was it they wanted--
they said, we want to call it--
oh, man, I wish I
could think of it.
They had another line from
"Star Wars" they wanted to use.
And it was terrible.
Because it sounded like I
was insulting geek culture.
It will come back
to me what it was.
Oh, it was, "I Have a
Bad Feeling About This--
Star Wars and the
Triumph of Geek Culture."
And I said, first
of all, I said,
that's like the biggest "Star
Wars" cliche you can possibly
imagine.
And I said, it's also
just completely wrong.
I love my publisher.
FSG is a great press.
They're a bit more
of a literary press.
They're not so much a geekier--
even like the science
fiction stuff they do,
they tend to do things
like the Southern Reach
trilogy and stuff.
So it's a little
more like literary.
They want to call it
speculative fiction stuff.
So anyway, I said, no, no,
no, that's completely wrong.
So then I was like, OK,
I'm on the hook now.
I better come up with a better
expression, a better line
from "Star Wars" or
else they're going
to completely ruin this book.
And you should have seen
the cover they originally
wanted to put on this, too.
It was like this sad, emo Darth
Vader like crying or something.
I was like, guys, you're
not marketing this book
to hipsters.
You're marketing it to geeks.
[LAUGHTER]
So, and there's an intersection
between geeks and hipsters,
too.
But I said, this is
a book for geeks.
And so this book is a
defense of geek culture,
like I want to defend what's--
there's plenty of
books and articles
out there telling you what's
wrong with geek culture.
This is a defense
of geek culture,
and it's a defense of
it on artistic grounds,
moral grounds, cultural grounds.
It's like a full-throated
defense of geek culture.
So I said, well,
how about this one?
I actually went through.
I just watched
"Star Wars" again.
I wrote down anything that could
possibly be a title in front of
[LAUGHTER]
And finally I went,
OK, how about,
"I find your lack of
faith disturbing,"
because I thought that
one works because it means
two different things, right?
Like it's true.
If you're a geek, on some
level, when you meet non-geeks,
especially if you find out
those non-geeks are going to be
in charge of making the new
"Star Wars" movie or the new--
you get scared.
Because you find their
lack of faith disturbing.
It's like you don't want them
to be in charge of making--
the best example would
be like Michael Bay
making the "Transformers"
movies, right?
A lot of people who are geeks
hate the "Transformers" movies
because they're not very geeky.
And so when Michael Bay was
going make "Turtles" movies,
people get scared, right?
So there's that.
You want to find out instead
that people you trust
and who are fellow geeks
are making these things.
But at the same time,
I think the people
who are outside
geek culture, there
is something a little like--
it looks a bit maybe like a
cult or a religion or something.
So it kind of goes both ways.
It is like these geeks--
and again, that's from
my own experience.
I remember being 15
years old, 14 years old
and going over to
my friends' houses
and talking to their parents
about the "Princess Bride"
and why they should watch it
and probably talking about it
for like an hour and them
being like, why is he just
talking about this, this movie
and this book for like an hour?
It's crazy.
It's absurd.
So yeah, it kind of
cuts both ways, I think.
So I wanted to get that
duality in the title,
if that makes sense.
But they made me put
something on the front.
I wouldn't have thought
of it on my own.
[LAUGHTER]
That's a market
force at work on me.
I don't know why they
had to have the title,
but they say it sells better
if you have the title.
Although now they refer to it
as "I Find Your Lack of Faith
Disturbing," and
I'm like, I'd rather
call it "Star Wars and
Triumph of Geek Culture."
That gets more to what
the book is about.
But they keep calling it "I Find
Your Lack of Faith Disturbing."
JOSH PYLE: All right,
and with that, I
think we have come to
the end of the hour.
I would love to
ask more questions,
but we have to sadly end.
But thankfully, you're
going to be sticking around
for a few minutes.
A.D. JAMESON: Oh, yeah, and if
people want me to sign copies
or if you had a question and
you didn't get a chance to ask,
I'd love to hear it.
JOSH PYLE: We have books
for sale in the back.
And Adam will be
sticking around.
The book is "I Find Your
Lack of Faith Disturbing--
'Star Wars' and the
Triumph of Geek Culture."
Thanks, Adam.
A.D. JAMESON: Thank you.
And thanks to everybody.
JOSH PYLE: Thanks, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]